[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue à tous nous sommes
ravis de vous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle émission dans vie de lecture
une émission très gourmande
aujourd'hui avec pauline bonjour et
laurent où je recevrai la librairie du
pavé du canal toujours toujours
alors aujourd'hui vous avez préparé une
émission livre de cuisine recettes
est-ce que bien vive bien manger voilà
d'accord c'est vrai que tu bien neutre
alors on va commencer tout de suite avec
on mange quoi ce soir monsieur le
especial gré donc il est un deuxième
ouvrage est la suite de mange quoi son
charme est là uniquement tout ce qui est
végétarien mais pas seulement
légumineuses aussi voilà donc ils
déclinent beaucoup de céréales que l'on
croise assez fréquemment dans nos
assiettes donc à chaque fois elle
procède sur quelles sont les quantités à
venir manger ce soir quel temps de
cuisson quel temps de préparation à ces
20 minutes un we are we may 20 minutes
sa technique de fond un peu plus mais on
perd là actifs qui rentrent le soir et
qu'ils se dépêchent de faire à manger
pour leur tribu ou pour m
donc ça veut tourner autour du millier
du pil pil tous et tous ces céréales la
cnaas et ben voilà qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire avec ça et donc il ya plein de
plats qu'on connaît pas bien
et ouais ça fait vraiment exemple alors
moi je restais ou pas j'ai testé une
fois sur la polenta il ya un plat tout
autour de la polenta avec des courgettes
et vraiment c'est très très bon et c'est
vrai que oui pour faut quand même une
petite demi heure 20 minutes a glissé un
peu mais
mais voilà donc quand kate sait des
choses assez simples à faire et à mettre
en place c'est toujours très coloré
c'est toujours très beau et vraiment
c'est un vrai plaisir quoi elle craque
que gustatif un peu dans cette mode un
peu tendance oui jacob un peu verte un
peu végétalienne on peut bien être
c'est ça même si les céréales font un
peu de kilomètres pour venir juste comme
nos assiettes remuaient voilà ça reste
autour de cette thématique et sylvia
gabet du coup c'est une
je crois que c'est une auteure qui a été
récompensée nom plusieurs fois pour pour
ses ouvrages non je ne sais pas c'est
vrai que je crois qu'elle a obtenu
plusieurs prix elle a fait notamment des
ouvrages avec des grands des grands
cuisiniers des grands chefs des corps
mais j ai pas participé donc j'étais pas
là non des hausses du cac c'est
quelqu'un qui est expérimenté des livres
de cuisine
oui on mange quoi ce soir au val c'est
quand même une référence merci beaucoup
laurent on enchaîne ce site avec la
deuxième ouvrage qui est donc pâtisserie
vegan alors qu'est-ce qui nous parle ça
c'est vous police c'est un très bel
ouvrage de pâtisserie en dehors du fait
que ça concerne la pâtisserie vegan
c'est un livre avec de très belles
photos sur un fond noir un moindre
croissance et que la sublime est vrai
par la photo et donc l'idée c'est de
retrouver les grands classiques de la
pâtisserie
ouais donc pâtisseries viennoiseries
entre eux mais enfin des choses des plus
simples aux plus complexes
ouais et d'en donner une version
végétarienne voilà j'ai regardé un petit
peu donc en acclament la tarte tatin la
tropézienne ta feuille elle paris brest
était la plus grande d'asie
finalement la pâtisserie classique et
traditionnelle sans beurre sans eux
c'est ça qu'il faut non quand même que
le beurre la plupart du temps est
remplacé par la margarine les yeux sont
remplacés par du jus de pois chiches
donc ça permet de fixer les blancs qui
avaient leur neige
le jus de pois chiches alors on achète
des pois chiches fait 50 ans qu'elles
donnent vraiment toutes les écoutes les
petits airs technique voilà pour pour
obtenir déjà visuellement et puis
gustativement quelque chose qui se
rapproche le plus possible des
pâtisseries traditionnelles là pour
remplacer les graisses animales les
crises des toilettes et autres
ingrédients qui souffre est aujourd'hui
considéré un peu plus comme une cifq
quoi pour notre corps exactement
d'accord mais la question c'est ce qu'on
a besoin de se rapprocher de l'objet
enfin du plat original mais pour faire
avec c'est quoi l'intérêt de manger une
tarte tatin vegan au final que c'est une
question de tradition culinaire c'est
que
de rendre accessible aux personnes qui
veulent pas consommer de protéines
animales des grands classiques que ce
soit par conviction ou par entre les
renseignements et les allergies
pourquoi passer très bonne idée donc on
se dit que manger vega n'est pas
forcément manger des choses qui
ressemblent à rien oui voilà c'est pour
changer du tofu et n'est pas une
apparente gourmande en tout cas très
bien
ouais ouais ça passe aussi par là par le
plaisir des yeux quoi exactement
il fermait en tête de proposer à des
gens qui sont un peu réfractaires à la
clé jacques jolivet gagnent de leur
montrer qu'on peut faire des choses
classiques de s'y retrouver voilà de les
adapter
voilà très bonne idée merci beaucoup
allez on enchaîne avec les semaines
légère de sophie c'est la fameuse
officielle avec dassault fils de take 2
qui n'a pas l'échec des sachets soit
alors là c'est sûr des recettes très
légère donc elle revient avec ses
conseils donc c'est ya petit déj il ya
un peu de cuisine végétarienne les plats
de poissons et de viandes lac et des
desserts et donc ses bas comme on peut
connaître d'habitude chez les dents les
cakes de sophie à tous la recette est
toujours son conseil à elle pour
justement réussir
alors là pour le coup moi c'est le
cheese cake au saumon fumé qui me
plairait bien
donc voilà je consulte un cheesecake ça
arrive ouais ça change un peu et la
tarte de pastèques aussi de pastèques de
pastèque qui peut être intéressante
aussi à explorer donc voilà si c'est
bien ce malgré les semaines légère de
sophie ça compense un peu les week-ends
gourmands de sophie et atteint ouvrages
précédents étaient sur une autre
thématique ou un peu plus riches et un
peu plus sucré mais la voilà c'est pour
varier un peu avec des crudités avec
beaucoup de berre aussi là car ça change
tout c'est de retrouver votre cheese
cake là mais je n'ai pas chaud 58 ça va
merci d'accord pas 658 que je montre la
petite photo du plat préféré à 6k qu'aux
mais c'est celui de la couverture donc
ça il faut compter
pas encore j'y travaille on va jouer des
je vais participer le portail web non je
vais tenir le livre aussi ah oui bon bah
chouette
merci donc là aussi printanier j'ai vu
qu'il y avait des fleurs aussi qui
étaient utilisés dont l'heure du ton
monte très original dont le deux super
allez on continue alors
avec anti gaspi me semble-t-il voilà
tout à fait de sonia ezgulian cebu
pacific directement mais violences et
parlent peut-être alors ça c'est ça
c'est vraiment chouette
- l'idée la deuxième ouvrage c'est
d'utiliser tout ce qu'on a dans son
frigo
donc on l'achète ou convainquons l'oubli
où on veuille s'en servir pour une
recette moi il reste toujours des fanes
de radis des épluchures de pastèques des
deux salades pas très fraîche sachant
que les français quand j'ai vu qu'il y
avait dix millions de déchets de tonnes
de déchets par an c'est michel mahler
mais lisez c'est de la marina mais un
rapport de l'uefa ou là et ça parle de
milliards de tonnes on a tous les ans
qui étaient gaspillés dans avec les gens
du voyage donc effectivement elle
propose une solution pourrait passer de
rekem aéré de consommer absolument tout
ce qu'on achète donc nos rangs parlé
tout à l'heure de la tarte à la pastèque
une recette de blanc de pastèques de
célèbres de blanc de pastèques aux
anchois
voilà donc c'est vraiment tout manger
alors sauf évidemment la peau de la
pastèque mais c'est de deux raclées au
maximum le fruit on commence on ne
consomme la chair puis effectivement le
blanc de pastèques et voilà donc il ya
toutes ces petites recettes avec c'est
pas des restes de lasagnes oui j'ai lu
alors finnois de pain rassis
voilà voilà on a
un pain de peaux de banane comme ça ça
fait moyennement oui bon les photos sur
toile et se sentent un pesto de dahmane
de radis oui les fanes de radis on peut
le décliner sur plein de choses que je
suis les pins de peaux de banane fait
beau tenter aussi la flammekueche du
lendemain non mais c'est une très très
bonne idée et puis j'aimais qu'elle elle
prône également la conservation sous
vide
oui c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement apparemment utilisé à la
mode outre atlantique et pas du tout ici
en france non avec ce n'est pas quelque
chose qu'on sait que leur
restructuration
exact c'est plus qu'on jouait
réfrigération ranger la scion et en quoi
donc je sais pas si on reconnais c'est
quelque chose c'est qu'ils sont filmés
c'est parce que ça change mais elle en
parle beaucoup elle a gagnent aussi
plein d'astuces en fait pour conserver
et là il est lumineux leur donner une
seconde jeunesse sur les salades par
exemple voilà de les mouiller et les
mettre dans du à une température très
froide en fait pour réveiller un peu une
salade mais voilà elle donne plein de
petites astuces comme ça et puis des
recettes des solutions à celle risotto
de patte cassée
oui l'idée c'est qu'il nous reste
toujours au fond du sachet de pâtes des
pâtes en petits morceaux pointe lui est
cher san jose et voilà deux
j'utilisais voilà ses manières un peu
rougis c'est vraiment chouette rafa
donne très envie
est-ce que ce qu'on fait est ce que est
ce que c'est quelque chose qu'on fait
vraiment mais en tout cas en russie mais
frais
et voilà l'axé livre on a n'a plus
aucune excuse pour essayer en tout cas
en tout cas pour essayer merci beaucoup
on continue avec les 50 aliments qui ont
changé le cours de l'histoire ça c'est
fantastique ce livre oui en fait ça
c'est pour eux aussi les amateurs
d'histoire pas que les culinaire mais
oui 6 à 2 à nîmes en fait ils prennent
l'aliment alors on prend par exemple la
mayonnaise qui a été fait au xvème
siècle et donc on explique son histoire
sociale culturelle commerciale commence
assez développée et comment sa vie
et voilà ils prennent et enfin c'est un
très beau très beau livre bien illustré
vraiment et c'est pratiquement un livre
de sciences humaines qui nous fait
découvrir en fait les aliments de tous
les jours qu'on consomme vraiment tous
les jours et ça décline vraiment ça
passe de la patate au cassoulet aux
soupes campbell mais ça crée le lien
fait entre l'alimentation et le
développement de nos civilisations
annoncé sa fin et il le niveau aussi
commercial dont il y à tous ces échanges
commerciaux qui ont pu avoir lieu
d'accord ça explique un peu comme en bas
on a développé le thé comme ont la
patate est venue voilà c'est vraiment
très intelligente on a l'impression
qu'ils sont là puis toujours surtout aux
générations enfin
c'est intéressant de sa moyenne est qu
elle a quel a été leur impact
là j'ai découvert que la nouille c'était
moins de 2000 ans avant jésus-christ
donc je ne savais pas que c'était aulas
nous y vas tu savais pas que c'était si
ancien que ça et voilà enfin on découvre
vraiment beaucoup de choses quoi c'est
vraiment passionnant d'accord
fantastique merci et enfin pour finir
parce que nous n'avons plus beaucoup de
temps la méthode jo x
pauline c'est vous qui avez oui alors
c'est une méthode de diététique et de
sport dans l'objectif de perdre du poids
l'idée c'est de pas passer son temps et
ses journées ni à cuisiner à faire du
sport et n'y a pensé à son régime toute
la journée
le principe c'est 15 minutes pour
réparer le la recette 15 minutes de
sport et ça n'en connaissent que très
intelligent c'est que il propose
vraiment cette double pratiques cuisine
sport et qui s'adapte en fonction woods
avait fait du sport des drones manger
des pâtes
si aujourd'hui vous avez décidez pas en
faire il va faire un menu plus légers
voilà deux portants du coaching
au final adaptée au cas par cas dans
c'est un vrai business men ce type c'est
un anglais un auteur anglais alors il a
vraiment des millions de followers sur
facebook sur instagram et c'est un sacré
un sacré phénomène et c'est c'est
vraiment un auteur à succès oui puis les
recettes qui propose à son hyper
protéiné donc c'est pas pour pour les
vegans voilà c'est ça a l'air plutôt
appétissant et il va les adapter en fait
vous avez deux parties dans le livre une
partie pour les périodes on fait
beaucoup de sport où on en fait moins
est vide et c'est d'alterner en fait
c'est de ces deux types d'alimentation
merci accompagné de sport super merci
beaucoup on va essayer ça aussi avant
les vacances avant le maillot merci de
nous avoir suivi et à très bientôt pour
une nouvelle émission dans les lectures
[Musique]